foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  he already left this moment and now I'm  living in 2022 in Qatar we hope the best  for our country and see you next round  see you  [Music]  uh it's been a long time we didn't  qualified Nick strong to today it's like  a chocolate variety everyone in Morocco  it's uh yeah thank you thank you okay  everyone more often is too happy  thank you until that's thoughtful it's  like something which is holy for us so  everyone is happy I cannot describe my  feelings right now they have been trying  so hard like for for too many years to  be in this position right now open  everywhere it has people opening we are  so proud with our national team also  because it's the first Arab  team to be in this position  [Applause]